let me show you where this is headed i
found this article from march 4th today
from defector it's titled i watched a
ben shapiro movie by accident
how do you watch how do you go to the
daily wire by accident sure whatever but
they write quote
if you're looking for something to watch
shut-in is pretty fun and vincent gallo
gets his ass kicked if you're in that
sort of thing that's a tweet i wrote a
couple weeks ago late on saturday night
it no longer exists the reason it
doesn't exist is because almost
immediately after i posted it i got a dm
from a friend uh you know that movie was
produced by the ultra right-wing daily
wire
with only ultra right-wing producers
talent and so forth for that market uh
what no no delete delete what yep
they're trying to make real movies now
sneak that ish and under the actual
cover of actual production values for
f's sake this always happens to me it
always happens to you huh i will be
watching an ultra evangelical movie and
not realize it's ultra evangelical i
will be listening to christian radio and
not realize it's christian radio if
jesus is around i need him to announce
himself or i'll just think he's from
brooklyn
brooklyn that's hilarious here's the
funny thing how do you accidentally
listen to ultra christian radio and be
like wait
are these are these biblical topics
christian
who is this person who's like i actually
look what they're saying they're saying
i enjoy conservative content i enjoy
these movies i enjoy christian radio oh
no i'm not supposed to delete delete
delete yeah that's how you know you're
dealing with a cult right exactly they
like some typical cult behavior it's a
cult man you know i watched disney i i
went and i went i saw ghostbusters 2016.
i regretted it but i'll go see those
movies and then i went and saw the new
ghost news ghostbusters i liked it
i watch uh uh i read the daily wire you
know i check out
the stuff they're producing or whoever
because i'm like oh someone can make
something good it's good i'm now getting
to the point where i'm like get away
from these companies that hate you and
want to take your money for bad things
but maybe that's kind of the mentality
they've always had and and the you know
libertarian civil libertarian or
conservative side is only just now
realizing it for the longest time
conservatives have been content to give
their money to people who hate them and
the left has always been against giving
their money to people who hate them i
don't think conservatives realized how
much these people hated them because i
don't think they realized what was
brewing um in the sort of academic on
the fringes of the academic left which
was this thing that i've called the
progressive or bigot binary which is
that you are either necessarily
progressive or a bigot so if you are not
fully progressive at every turn and you
don't agree with every little tenet of
our idea or our faith i should say then
you are a bigot if you fall just outside
of that you're a bigot and when you
enforce that i just don't think a lot of
conservatives realized that this is what
was building that like if you disagree
with them um if you disagree with them
at all it's not just that you think
clarence thomas is innocent because it's
the early 90s now it's if you think
brett kavanaugh is innocent you are
responsible um for being you're
complicit in rape um and you have uh you
you have created violence against women
i don't you know i just i don't care
about what these people think
in terms you know to a certain degree
because because of things stories like
this right it's it's it's just what we
we we've the country's bifurcated the
there was a there was a period where we
had a culture war i think the culture is
just totally bifurcated like a thousand
times over and over and over and over
and over i mean pockets of weirdness
when when we started when the culture
first began depending on what you think
is the first great moment in it it could
be occupy wall street because that's
where i think the issue is most people
didn't see the workers in the
organization of occupy yes but gamergate
was pronounced widespread on the
internet and was bubbling up and
creating these personalities who were
you know always viewed themselves as
being on the left but now viewed
themselves as being called right wing
at that time
we were still very much interested in a
lot of the same things just disagreeing
on them now we're at a point where it's
like you guys go make your the craft
remake which is just a woke psa and ben
shapiro and the daily wire will make
regular movies that we'll watch right
and that's the thing that ben shapiro
and the daily wire get is that they need
to make regular movies and that has not
happened before that's the big
difference between what they're doing
and all of the other so-called
conservative art that's come before them
i've got a lot of friends on facebook
from the old days when i was a
progressive bigot like you're saying i
was like oh they don't they don't they
want me to whatever okay um they're like
now they're they're talking about
serving other people this new the show
with zielinski is the the lead right and
they're like oh i hear this show's okay
i can't wait to see it they're like yeah
man i loved it i'm definitely watching
this and i know what i got queued up
netflix just put back on
in the midst of the ukraine war netflix
just brought servant of the people which
is zelinski's is it was a sitcom where
he played the president of ukraine uh
back in 2015 then he ran and actually
became the president of ukraine so
netflix us has now put netflix put this
back on netflix in english i feel like
they're watching it because ukraine got
invaded it's pure call oh yeah yeah yeah
it's it's it's ridiculous
i mean it's just obvious you go on
facebook and i see all these people
their their profiles are ukraine flags
now they're posting memes they're
they're saying like things about
zelinski people are saying like cuomo is
out zolensky's in or whatever and i'm
just like oh god you guys have no idea
what you're talking about you're
literally in a cult and you know why you
know it's this simple
you ask someone what do you think about
ukraine a not cult member says you know
i've heard about in the news honestly
i'm not not real you know following
following it i don't like the war so
russia sucks for invading but i wouldn't
know a whole lot what do you think about
zolensky who's that he's the president
of ukraine oh no idea the cult members
are like yes yes ukraine flag and i'm
like why do you support ukraine because
big country invaded small country
the president is a comedian yeah and
that's all they need mm-hmm i think
there are people and then
and i love ian because he's like hey
who's this guy igor kolomoisky who seems
to be funding all of these things oh
yeah so kolomoisky started a tv show
by the way and the adar battalion
started funding them as private security
battalions for himself and his own
militia he was a governor at one point
we've all done that no we have we
haven't yet um
and uh and you know but we're not
supposed to ask questions about
kolomoisky no no no no no this is you
know
a liberal democracy that we all love
what about all those corruption reports
and hunter biden and barisma and all
this money and the podestas and manafort
and all of these things you know isn't
this like a human trafficking area
hasn't this been known for it obviously
we don't want it to be corrupt we would
like it to be you know a stable country
but you know what about all of this you
know reporting in fact dude the call of
moisty thing okay so he started serving
the people the tv show or he said he had
he ran or owned the network the network
that ran this show and then he hired
celinski to be that role and then he
started a political party called the
servant of the people named after the
show and then he got zielinski to be the
his candidate that's the most
transparent fascist crazy
his vision we'll call it call it
whatever you want i'll take it but this
this should be an example to everyone
listening why it's so important to build
culture why it's so important to make tv
shows make cartoons make jokes freedom
tunes has a new cartoon out today
i did the voice of doc it was a lot of
work we took like half an hour to record
this but uh if you guys aren't familiar
with sheamus on the show periodically
this is humor it's making fun of dr
fauci so the the joke that i don't wanna
you know you gotta watch it but the
general idea is dr fauci hasn't been on
tv in months or a month or plus
since everyone pivoted over to ukraine
from kovid so the joke is he keeps
calling like hello is anybody there like
why don't you answer your phone we're
making fun of what the establishment
props up with all the cult members when
they're all waving their flags and
claiming you know all these things and
saying how much they love fauci or when
uh stephen colbert had the dancing
syringes or whatever whatever he did
yeah or who was it who did the thing
where they spun uh from there's like a
camera angle going up jimmy kimmel no no
it was recording jim james
so we like we make fun of that that
gives people a space they feel like
they're not alone but also going back to
what you were saying before with the
daily wire and creating movies it's
showing all of these people who don't
like what's happening in their workplace
there is another place you can work i'll
tell you that in in addition to making
art that shows how ridiculous things are
you can make art like i can make a show
where you become the president and in
the show you're a hero and people love
you and you save the world and if that
people that becomes a popular enough
show people will want you to be the
president you know why they made men in
black right
no not no yeah you you guys know the
movie men in black of course yeah great
the government made that man listen
propaganda no because now now when you
try and prove that that men and black
are real no one believes you because
it's it's a movie man yeah no that's
that's experience that's an actual
conspiracy with the x-files too
there's actually a conspiracy theory
that the government funds movies so that
when you want to talk to someone about
the conspiracy theory they say that's a
movie dude what are you talking about
well so they do fund more movies than
people realize um
actually in in fact the new uh top gun
movie where the it kind of made
headlines because the bomber jacket
mavericks bomber jacket had the
taiwanese taiwanese flag and the
japanese flag taken off well it turns
out actually and if you really dig into
this the pentagon it sounds like a
conspiracy theory it isn't um actually
provided a lot of resources to that
movie and they used training drills
actually to be scenes in the movies so
it works out great for hollywood and it
works out great for the pentagon because
they want to have the u.s military look
good and all that stuff but what it
means is that our government resources
were complicit in moving the removing
the taiwanese flag from the bomber
jacket and it creates this ridiculous
cycle
but they absolute the pentagon
absolutely provides resources and what
you could clearly say is x amount of
dollars to these movies when you guys
were saying how we centralize stuff
three five and eight the three channels
you know it's very new it's very like we
had the printing press then all of a
sudden we had tv and we have the
centralized just tv itself and radio
it's gotta be mind controlling us like
crazy it's so new in our species
evolution well so what's wild is that
like and not not to delve too into
ukraine specifically but you look at the
reporting of it how many of the stories
that we see initially come out of
ukraine and then it goes 24 to 48 hours
and it's completely debunked right right
and that's because we have the system
that we have now but
prior to this did we have anybody going
you know how could you right how could
you go to the newspaper and understand
what was going on in world war ii
right because you weren't on the ground
we didn't have this sort of
instantaneous communication system like
we do now where we can communicate with
somebody in ukraine in russia in belarus
in poland literally in real time to
understand what's actually happening and
so we're getting these reports and this
is how people like walter durante for
the new york times were able to
completely cover up things like the
holiday war uh like people like edgar
snow in in china were able to talk about
uh the chinese cultural revolution and
the chinese great famine as if oh they
weren't happening is this wonderful
thing it's chinese communism right
because you didn't have somebody do that
so the question then becomes if that's
what's happening in ukraine and we can
see right we can see this stuff being
debunked everything almost within 24 to
48 hours or at least the initial frame
is always kind of like slightly
different like oh they hit you know they
hit a shopping mall oh wait but there
were tanks operating out of that
shopping mall and missile launchers
right um so it you know
you have to put in a different context
then what does that mean for the rest of
history his story
his story some dude wrote it story yeah
i don't buy it right i don't believe any
of it the bible that's all his story man
there's this uh
where the bible is there was this thing
we had back in the day when i was a
little kid called bathroom readers you
ever hear of them
they're big books that you were supposed
to buy full of trivia and you just like
put in your bathroom oh yeah yeah i only
on the on the bottom of every page was a
factoid and that's what i mostly enjoyed
reading but there's a story in one of
them about how
there's this great painting of american
revolutionary soldiers chasing off a
bunch of fumbling stumbling regulars and
they say that the original painting was
fumbling stumbling
a revolutionary you know continental
army fleeing well-regulated you know
british regulars and then every time the
the painting got recommissioned or the
story was retold it became more and more
lopsided in favor of the the us
because you know people were then five
years out from what actually happened
then 10 years out right and so someone
would tell the story of this battle and
it would get embellished a little bit
and then eventually
american patriotism they're going to be
like the americans they fought hard and
they chased away those spineless cowards
and then you get this image that's
totally unrealistic uh napoleon was
great at that he had paintings
commissioned of all his officers his top
ones and make them all look beautiful
and like you know they're not that they
weren't but they weren't those in
photography so my take on this is that
um when you look at like instagram
culture now and filters and you know
photoshopping and face app and all of
that that's just that's just what humans
have been doing for years but only the
elites could actually afford it so
whoever was commissioning the sculpture
right with the emperor of rome well of
course they're going to say you know
you're going to make me look like this
perfectly chiseled you know features and
everything or the pharaoh or the king or
whatever aristocrat it was um but then
like the first english queen that we
actually have photos of i think is queen
victoria so look at a photo of victoria
next to the painting of queen victoria
and you're like hey wait a second what
would donald trump say about queen
victoria right
i don't know what what's her thing
no
seeing if you present donald trump with
a picture of queen victoria how does he
react
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you